here's where I've begun the parabola
easy bit x squared you know exactly what
that looks like the +1 its moves it up
happy times let's point out two things
before we get on to your own just one
thing I'm sure is Labor we actually it's
healthy to label your accident right
this is the x axis over here usually you
would call the vertical one you usually
call it the y axis today I'm not going
to call the y axis can anyone tell me
why fun because I haven't written doubt
away anywhere on the board there is no
why okay we usually call the why there's
no problem with that but I'm in function
notation Wainwright so instead I want to
call this guy up here informatics okay
that's fine now just to give you a bit
of a tip when you see questions and
their phrase in this way sometimes
they'll just don't just come out and say
um let y 0 x and then they'll tell you
what f of X is just like I have right in
which case if you want you can label
that thing why because y + f of X
they're exactly the same that's that's
what that line means okay but in this
case I've no wise so I'm going to speak
clear of them now if that's the case
what is what is this thing going to look
like okay now we actually i showed you
before but it was just kind of like Oh
computer told me but why is it that we
actually have enough tools to work out
what this thing is going to look like
part of its hard is it there's a plus or
minus on there right what mathematicians
classically do is if there's something
that's difficult you just consider
something similar but easier and then
see if you can take that understanding
growing okay so let's just consider one
part of it let's just consider this guy
what's the inverse okay now remember
we've talked about like to remain and
range in the last to be lessons okay and
we've looked at functions like this can
you help me work out what the domain and
range of this function is ok now let's
think of domain first think of domain
first what values can work in this thing
versus what values can't what kinds of
things are going to break this because
some things will break it right
yeah what I want to avoid is negative
numbers under this square root your
negative under their kind of up the
creek without a paddle okay so therefore
what I want is for that thing underneath
the square root which is X minus 1 I
want it to be not negative now not
negative sounds like positive does it
it's almost I'm missing one number what
number I missing off their 00 is 50 is
not negative so I'm gonna include all
right so X minus 1 it's greater than
equal to 0 you can solve that that's
really easy to solve what do i do I just
add 1 to both sides don't I so i'll get
x is greater than or equal to 1 there's
my domain ok so that's where i can go
horizontally let's think about the range
now okay the range now this is square
root this is a square root no matter
what numbers you put into this thing
right like okay you can try one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
that's all you can put in do you see
you're always going to get something
that's zero or higher you see that right
like what I put in x equals one that's
that's the edge of my domain i get the
square root of one minus one which is
zero when i put in x equals like five
right I'm going to get the square root
of five take away one just wear it for
that'll be true I'm getting bigger on
time I'm never getting smaller okay so
therefore the conclusion a draw is the
range is that I have to be greater than
or equal 0 okay all right now I know
where I can go domain is one and on
range 0 and up okay what's it going to
look like if you test some values you'll
get this kind of shape okay all i need
to do is plot some points to verify that
and i actually we just did a few of them
i said x equals 1 y will equal 0 x
equals 4 12 oh no no no no sorry x
equals 5
now I said we would take this and would
simplify it done I'm missing Clough
aight aight i'm missing this part this
is the minus part of the plus or minus
right so I've done the positive now I'm
going to do the negative let's think in
terms of domain and range again what's
the difference between the domain of
this file and the domain of this guy
domain domain that's been sneaky this
one it's a deliberate curveball why did
I work out up here that X minus one has
to be greater than or equal 0 why did
you tell me that because a negative will
destroy good healthy a negative
importantly a negative under the square
root will destroy the whole thing that's
what question trouble ok now what's
underneath the square root here it's
it's exactly the same thing isn't it x
minus one x minus one so the domain of
this function this function are
identical they're not different they
start the same thing under the square
root so the same things going to destroy
both of them right so I can still say X
minus one is going to be greater than or
equal to 0 so therefore X is might be
greater than or equal one domain is the
same but now when you have a look at
range range is different right test some
values and it's very easy to see right
we'll start at x equals 1 because that's
in the domain mine x equals 1 what's
this thing going to be equal to what's F
the inverse of 1 you just get zero here
would you but as you start to put in
more numbers right like what's put in
five let's do this f of the universe of
I am dutifully going to replace all of
my exes with fires right so it's gonna
explode minus square root of five take
away one that's minus the square root of
four that's negative terrain and in fact
the more exes you put in the bigger
those X's get the more negative Y is
going to go it's going to keep dropping
right so in fact the range of this guy
is the opposite of the range of this guy
it's the other way less than or equal to
0 okay it's going down on that basis and
if I wanted to I would try out some
value I know that the other parts going
to look like this it's just that graph
upside down okay in the same way that if
i gave you x squared you knew where they
look like and if i stop a minus sign on
it goes upside down okay so yeah okay
now now that we can see it now this part
is obvious right do you remember in the
very first lesson I said how you know if
something's a function or not okay you
either say how many inputs how many
apples so I have or you get a vertical
line right and you put it on any way you
like okay if your vertical line kits
more than once that means you've got
more than one output right and I'm
busted okay pretty quickly a bustling so
that's why this guy is not a function no
inverse function now I could have known
that I could have known I wouldn't have
got a function right from the beginning
right you remember we did this really
quick excite I asked you to rotate your
heads do you remember that I said turn
your heads 45 degrees this way I'm going
to put the line in and I want you to do
the same the line I want you to print is
y equals x looks like this passes
through the origin and it goes off at a
45-degree angle like sir this F inverse
this is the reflection of the original
function across y equals x right that's
how I get this thing because the
reflection it's the same as actually
taking it and retaining around 90
degrees through a right angle you see
that okay so therefore if this passes
tried this fails this vertical line test
right what would it look like on the
original function what happens when you
take a vertical line and you rotate it
90 degrees you don't get a vertical line
you get a or here's a vertical line and
you rotate it and you get up horizontal
lines right so before I did any of this
algebra business I could have looked at
the original graph instead hey if I put
a horizontal line across there it failed
I have two inputs right so therefore
once I rotate it of course I'm going to
get two outputs okay so here's my
conclusion off of making that saver
right if they are if a graph passes the
vertical line test right we know the
function that's fine okay if it fails
it's not going to be a function like a
circle or something like that okay but
if I want to get an inverse for what
again universe I don't want a vertical
line to go through it I want a
horizontal line to go through it right
so this is what happens from the
vertical line test if a graph passes the
horizontal line test
then it's not that it's a function
necessarily but it will have an inverse
function now if we go back to a very
very first example which was just a
straight line right whatever was y
equals 3x plus 1 or something like that
okay oh I just on top here we go y FX
equals a xmas one can you see this
passes the vertical line test so it's a
function that is there you can put any
medical line through there you like so
tick it's a functioning right but not
only can i put a vertical line through
it i can also put in any horizontal line
I like okay therefore it also does this
has an inverse function it's going to be
fine right and that's why we worked it
out and you get to this equation okay
it's that same thing by the way if you
take y equals x migraine dotted line you
can place it through again and again
when you rotate your head you can see
the reflection coming across do you see
that